David I'm signing you to the Home Secretary very good Ma'am
It's a move up
Mom, this is PС Budd. Pleasure to meet you, Ma'am. I'm late for a meeting
She's got an agenda to heighten fear and to seize power
That doesn't require apologizing for the past. Did you mean what you said? I don't need you to vote for me
need to protect me. Rest assured, Ma'am
I'll do what's required
Stay down. It's okay. It's okay
These plots do not always arise from outside, some fester within
I've been a copper. I've been a soldier for
politicians, cowards and liars
What is she up to? You need to find out
How do you reckon she'd feel if she got a taste. You cannot keep pretending you are okay? This is a very
dangerous politician someone's gonna stop her
There's been an Inside Man all along looks like the Home Secretary couldn't be in safer hands